i got pepper sprayed yeah didn't it hurt
that's what i always asked knoxville
what hurt most of the yeah defense test
he's always said he always says pepper
spray and yeah i i
i've never been shot by a gun thank god
but but pepper spray is horrible like
it's so gnarly it's so gnarly after i
got pepper sprayed i told every girl
like your little taser thing like throw
that away it does nothing that's what i
tell people i know and i give girls that
i know like pepper spray in south africa
i gave everyone pepper spray i was like
yeah carry this with you and then they
go out for a walk not bringing the
pepper spray get mugged and like why
didn't you have that i told you
you practiced it like because seriously
it should give you so much confidence
like yeah the good stuff
you're just shut down
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you